I would say that some of the groups in
whose hands economic power is
concentrated cannot forgive us for
creating social movements especially the
indigenous populations movement which
has changed the image of our beautiful
country they also cannot forgive us for
nationalizing our natural resources and
strategic companies which has improved
Bolivia's economic system upon the
successful creation of a developed
lithium industry mr. Alvaro and I
planned to set lithium prices on the
world market I realized though that some
industrialized countries are afraid to
compete first in the field of
technological development and second
they do not want other countries to
follow the example of our economic model
which is based on socialism I've learned
in my life that you never choose a
position it finds you this applies from
the position of Trade Union had right up
to the post of president there is an
official report confirming I won the
first round this is a very extensive
report you can check it at any time you
can see the election results but there
is an important point to be made there
was an agreement that the Organization
of American States was supposed to
publish the official report last
Wednesday around 2:00 p.m. that was the
arrangement but unexpectedly on Sunday
morning they called us and informed us
that the preliminary report was ready we
requested this report clinicas and there
was complete confusion one part of it
said that I won and that Carlos Meza
came second but this did not prove that
I won the election in the first round I
ordered that I be put in touch with Luis
Almagro
but I was not connected the report was
published on Sunday morning I spoke with
the representative of the Organization
of American States and told him verbatim
if you do not double-check your report
it will cause unrest in Bolivia and
there will be victims by publishing its
reports the Organization of American
States actually supported the coup who
is in charge of everything now people
from the US and Jorge - Tokui ragga a
follower of hugo banzer who for seven
years ruled Bolivia as a dictator I was
called an authoritarian ruler a dictator
but this is not so these are real
dictators on the other hand new
generations will now understand what a
real dictatorship is
you